what a difference a month makes plan b's
gone cases are falling shoppers are
returning and there's optimism too from
the vaccine maker moderna the chief
medical officer believes we're coming
out of the pandemic phase but in an
interview with sky news he said the
variants that have caused so much recent
misery are likely to return a modernist
preparing a super booster for the autumn
we think omicron will still be here this
is a virus that you can't eradicate i
don't think anytime soon
so right now pragmatically we're going
with an omicron booster but we think we
may need to combine it with another
messenger rna that can give us some
delta protection too i am confident that
we can get to a once yearly vaccine and
our aspiration is to couple that with
flu we're going to start testing that
later this year so then you can go to
your pharmacy or your doctor and get a
single covert flu injection
get tuned up for winter protected and we
would hope to actually be able to bring
that out in the winter of 2023.
but modena is keeping a close eye on ba
0.2 the new version of omicron latest
data from the uk health security agency
shows it spreads even more easily than
the original omicron variant and while
it's not yet clear whether it causes
more severe disease the vaccine is just
as effective nevertheless scientists say
it could prolong the omicron wave
we've got this uh this new kid on the
block the um
ba 0.2 which is
um
at the moment seems to be doubling every
week or so in in case numbers and
so at some point
when ba
0.2 becomes dominant we could well see
cases rising again
there are now three closely related
versions of omicron there were 200 of
delta evolution doesn't stop and the
vaccine manufacturers can't drop their
guard just because covered cases are
currently falling
thomas more sky news